Hausa Gomez - Peter Pan this game looks
scary as hell
it even has my name in it I'm Fay beds
as you can see it's a pre-alpha
so it's not a finished product but let's
check it out anyway oh well this room
looks great let's go in here this is
such a [ __ ] trap okay fine fine I'm
alive oh god I knew it I knew there was
something bad about this place okay be
careful pits I thought yeah I'm supposed
to collect pages oh god that's creepy
man what the [ __ ] oh no what did I do
Teddy what happened oh god damn it Eddie
I clicked that the book and everything
this became bad okay
oh god damn it I swear to god man I've
come on bad radio bad radio oh god oh
god oh god oh god what's happening
what's happening oh god okay we're fine
we're fine
just hug the corner it's been forever
since I've played a horror game this is
freaking me out man okay hug the balls
it's all blood nice I was hoping there
would be blood cuz that means someone
got poked which is life in general isn't
it well this place has two toilets in
one bathroom holy [ __ ] I could pee and
poop at the same time well I guess
that's normal I can I think about it
game builds tension man I don't like it
Oh God hello oh god what happens in
there [ __ ] you I'm not going there what
what is going on in there
is that a note oh okay I got one of the
notes I didn't read it though because
I'm an idiot but I don't want you anyway
whoa whoa whoa whoa someone peed out
some stuff that was nuts
what what is going on here this is some
creepy [ __ ] man okay Bryce if I die
today I want you I love you and I wasn't
planning to eat all of you that's a
burrito I'm serious okay that's another
one man this game it's not scary at all
I could have been killed I was in charge
of a security of this place
ah the new chair Oh God Oh God another
share oh god he must be jealous
I hate when they're jealous the flop is
too late basically piss oh god oh god oh
god okay okay I got more blood shut up
shut up I took you at first Anna's only
appear at a corner I froze you're dating
[ __ ] your mother how about it
I got him suck what am i what am i doing
it's pity Pato said nearly doctor oh god
was that sound [ __ ] this man prefer ever
since I've been this [ __ ] scared
hello hello homicide that is not a
popping sound that is something else
hello I have a bad feeling about that
room I'm not gonna go that right now no
damn it
I nearly - dude - got it on day gage me
afraid of Conan I hear a note yes Nick
it off man why do they keep disappearing
hello
I hear a note in here or maybe it's
upstairs
no it's definitely down there hasta
Sarah
oh dear we're not going there nope nope
nope nope nope nope nope
just give me the note janab-i cinnabar
Oh God
oh god it wasn't open the dog open -
don't please hi hi hi oh god he's gone
oh no he's don't look at him look at him
that's fine baby baby why dr. Tandon a
note what the hell I don't understand I
don't understand what's going in wasted
no tell you what
tell me what's going on and tell me
Kenny tell me Teddy Teddy I love you
hello yes you got meat oh yeah you want
to run away to France
hey hey well I don't eat forgets I'm
sorry no no it's awesome 9 out of 10
doctors Splendora why is the last note
it's in the elevator
toilet toilet oh god they say come on
we're so close for ChaCha's yeah I'm
tired of you in your [ __ ] it's lagging
more than a man's hair slapping on this
speed of light
oh god oh god oh god oh god stop listen
no oh god it's you what are you trying
to do hey high five
okay cool I know doctor some notes I
keep clicking them away I'm really sorry
buddy
I don't know what to do about it it's
like I try and I try so hard
that's assumed second doctor alone you
know I really need to stop crying my god
it's a faker
Thank You Man Nosa my god favorite not
favorite that's favorite okay which way
left right left okay left oh god [ __ ]
Oh note I funny okay that's good oh god
oh god it's a fake
goddamnit you have died well no [ __ ] oh
god oh god oh god what what how did this
happen this I don't even have I'm my
[ __ ] light now hey man are you doing
good cool that looks like a chicken
I'll just be on my way thank you oh mama
mia pizzeria
ah okay six out of eight can't you tell
me how to stage I don't want to put
eight
hey it's yo cool cold you look like that
guy from me from Vendetta Vendetta
Guy Fawkes mask I don't think that's
attentional but I like your swag style
damn baby damn he sounds kind of like he
really wants me back see sage you watch
me day don't you watch me and I know I'm
not feeling that a nun and don't know
the lyrics
hey don't you punch me yes sir a note in
the bathroom taking a [ __ ] yes it is
a luminary open that it's not declining
oh that is kinda naughty petition I am
just sitting in that corner looking Josh
speech tt-that's corner table
how are you saying I thought we were
cool last five bit but prime example of
god damn who flipped the share the
tragedy guy what are you doing I got I'm
back let's finish this vision oh god oh
god man hey whoa whoa whispering no no
no you want to make camp how am I
supposed to kiss someone without a mouth
you're not wearing pants how many times
I gotta tell you just put on pants man
what will scream why did you scream
refrigerator I was the best yo Kevin
you're not moving inside me
well I guess you are [ __ ] that's why she
just don't know do you funny that left
fist open okay I just go in the room
what Lady Gaga I didn't know you were
here it's a tragedy
is he coming run down I got you ball
okay we got me just gotta make it out we
just got to make it out
Justin baby but what do you do when he
some say this game is scary
I ski that's all I got really what is
that oh god what the [ __ ] is that what
deaf [ __ ] a duck your stock aren't
you do it you just want a hug he isn't
that right East us Emma there's no
change what you can't have it what up
Oh goddamn bookshelf
oh god damn calm down everyone just tell
the [ __ ] out youtube chance you too I'm
running I'm gunning I'm flipping my
budget then right I'm squeezing the
really really tight shut up god damn it
that is not what I want hello
don't look back what are you doing you
[ __ ] what what he went what what okay
I'll take it I'll take a ten or ten best
game ever yes we were walking it was all
a dream
Teddy I'm back it was all a dream oh
good I can go back to fapping now we
finished it let's dance
all right price a lot of fun playing
this game it's been a while since I
played a really atmospheric and horror
so hope you enjoy watching leave a like
if you did I really appreciate it that's
a skyrim road today I see you breasts
I am just sitting in that corner looking
at - Beach tt-that's corner